Another practitioner wants me to start hydrogen peroxide. What are your thoughts with this?
I'll be starting mistletoe not sure what to do. I wrote a blog post on hydrogen peroxide that
you might want to look to. When you say another practitioner is wanting you to start hydrogen peroxide,
I think you're to say that you're doing oral hydrogen peroxide. Hydrogen peroxide for
let me share my screen here a second. Change my screen share real quick.
You can see my screen now. This is the blog post. Hydrogen peroxide for cancer not so fast.
And watch this video that I did on hydrogen peroxide. We talked about this a few weeks ago.
Hydrogen peroxide is H2O2 making it an unstable molecule. Well, that's the benefit of hydrogen peroxide.
It's an unstable molecule. It will give an oxygen away. It's not an oxygenizing product. It's
an oxidant just like chemotherapy is an oxidant. But hydro peroxide is not a stable oxidant. So
when you do hydro peroxide orally, you could kill bacteria in your gut. Well, that could be a good
thing to your bad thing because you could actually disrupt your floor on your bacteria. Hydro peroxide is
not going to be absorbed into your bloodstream and circulate around and go to the cancer and then give
its oxygen to the cancer and oxidate the cancer killing the cancer. It's just not going to do that.
Just so when there's alternative practitioners and practitioners that say you use hydrogen peroxide
orally, you know, this is where I struggle because you're not understanding some basic physiology.
Hydrogen peroxide is great as an oxidant and oxidizing agent that will kill bacteria and viruses
topically because it will readily give off that other oxygen, which is an O negative molecule.
And it will attach to a cell membrane of a bacteria and it will kill by the active of
being an oxidizing agent to damage the cell membrane and it destroys it. That's what a poisoned
is. So that's how chemotherapy works. It's a poison. It's an oxidizing agent that is a poison.
That's how hydrogen peroxide is. If you drink mood grade 35% hydrogen peroxide, you can kill yourself.
The award is not going to take that much. We're going to take a lower dose. Well, are you really
if you're not killing the cancer because it's not stable enough to be to travel and be absorbed
into the through the gut wall into the bloodstream and travel to the cancer and then give off its oxygen
there. So it makes me it makes okay, if I had maybe if I had stomach cancer, maybe using you know
hydrogen peroxide might be an option, but there's dangers to that too because it's a toxin.
So you have to be really careful with that. So I even with stomach cancer, I wouldn't recommend it
because there's just too many, too many downsides you could you could kill the patient.
So I'm not a phantom hydro peroxide, so you could read my article about that there.